3 large NGOs that help immigrants.
You are commenting on us,
eh?
By private message,
you have come to Spain.
and you want to apply for asylum,
but it is currently impossible.
It is completely saturated in the offices eh,
police,
in this case of foreigners,
to apply for political asylum.
You don't wonder where it costs to go?
We will briefly present 3 major NGOs.
that help the unfortunate,
to the immigrant.
Which ones are they?
The first one is Accem,
this NGO is specialized
particularly
in care of injured persons or situation
or persons in situation or at risk of exclusion.
I am reading it.
Next is CEAR,
Spanish commission for refugee assistance.
And finally,
we are talking about Caritas,
good thing,
because this particular one is um eh,
specializes in defending excluded persons,
elderly,
homeless